a little bit different today after we
did the video on Dijkstra I thought well
you know sometimes I like to go home and
sometimes just do a bit of programming
in front of a TV you know sort of
personal I am and one of the cool things
actually about being able to program is
if you think oh I wonder if I could
write something that would solve mazes
you can invent immediately go and do
that that thing so that's what we're
doing today I've come out of a bit of a
small program not very complicated that
soul mazes that you give it in image
form so you give it a maze it works its
way through it and then it outputs see
the same picture of a maze with a red
line on it it's all very exciting but
I've also actually implemented lots of
different search approaches so I've
implemented depth and breadth first
search and a style and Dijkstra if you
want to see the actual code for those
things then we'll make it available so
other people can follow along tweak it
maybe improve on what what I've done
this comes back down to Dave Brailsford
implementation videoed isn't it because
there are so many ways you could program
something that solves an image-based
maze and how I've done it is ok it
probably isn't the optimal I had in mind
I wanted to do really big mazes you know
15 thousand pixels by 15 thousand pixels
maybe bigger I've run out of RAM now so
I can't do any bigger than that but so I
kind of want it to be most semi
efficient at the very least you know not
completely impractical so I sort of
started by coming up with some some
rules that my maze that have to follow
because yeah ok so I could I could give
it any maze any picture made with your
photograph of a maze but then most of
the time I'm going to be doing image map
is trying to turn that into a structure
in memory and that's all a job right you
don't have yeah I mean yeah and I'm just
doing this in front of a TV you know
it's not me carried away so what I've
said was I'd have a black-and-white
pixel image that hopefully doesn't have
JPEG compression on it because that just
makes everything there's a black border
all the way around the outside that's
the wall and then any black pixel is
wall any white pixel is path and there's
an entrance at the top and an exit at
the bottom that's that with my both of
my rules I obviously other route mazes
that don't follow those rules aren't
going to work in my software you can buy
all me to extend my software to have a
bit closer made as if you want I've got
a small image here called tiny dot PNG
which you can't see because Windows does
not like to expand these kind of size of
images what you don't do is give it the
15,000 by 15,000 image first go because
if you have any kind of problem you have
no idea what went wrong maybe if you
start on a small image you can actually
sort of debug what's going on in the
code you can say well I was expecting
this to happen and it didn't which means
I've made a mistake or something like
this so start off with a small cases and
then work your way up to the bigger
thing and hopefully once you've gotta
bust a gram that works on small image on
small mazes just give it a big amazing
it should fingers crossed work first
time we shall see so I've drawn a maze
right that took ages to draw you didn't
video it but you know just scribbling
all this in not a bit wayward here but
you know each of these squares is a
square and I have enough nothing more
said about it than that
so my lures are that the outside is
black apart from the top has one pixel
of white which is the entrance and the
bottom has one pixel of white which is
the exit those are my moves I've come up
with now as I said there are loads of
ways we could solve this maze
programmatically perhaps the first one
that I did and it so in the most obvious
one is just to put this image into
memory and then kind of freak pixel look
at the neighbors and see if we can go
there and then move there and if maybe
we can go a bit further and so on so
that was my kind of first trial
implementation what I did was like I
copied it into memory I store it as an
array and then I say that's my start
position at a naught 1 2 3 naught right
and so I said well look where can I go
from free naught well well the left
pixel to naught is black so call me
there and the next pixel across for
naught is black longer there but this
one isn't this 3 1 is white so I'll go
there and then I'll continue my search
from there and I do the same sort of
look art look down look less look like
processed and every pixel right this is
basically a flood fill but it's nothing
smart about this and it does work in the
sense that it will get into the end it
won't do it very quickly you have to
have a small rule but says which nodes
have been visited if you otherwise
you're just going to go up and down and
up and
up and down and up and down and get
yourself into a loop or here with actual
corn actual loop we might just go round
and round if we don't have any idea
about where we've been so I created
another array of the exact same size as
this which was a true or false array a
boolean array and just if you've been
visited you see it set to true and we'll
ever go back there right because by
definition we don't want to go back
where we've come from
right well what if you get into a dinner
partially so the data structure that I'm
using to do this breadth first search is
it's one that keeps a bit like I'd like
to approach in our previous video keep
the track of all the nodes that
currently are under consideration that
haven't been visited yet so you know if
it's been looking down here and I'll
have this one and maybe this one and
maybe this one and when it gets to a
dead end here it'll just go over and
work out and it will fall back to this
one so it kind of inherently allows
itself to sort of backtrack if I was
doing it as uses as you sort of
suggested which was that I just kind of
follow things blindly then I'm going to
be doing a lot of backtracking now I
have actually implemented a version of
that which we much we're sort of naive
let's turn version as well because I got
a bit carried away and implemented a few
different approaches the problem with
with what I did here by which is why I'm
not showing you the code at this
particular version is that it's a bit
inefficient right it's not massively
inefficient in memory because the Rays
don't take up a huge amount memory even
for a really big image you know you know
we load these kind of images when we
take high-resolution photographs and
things so it's not it's not
inconceivable that you would have that
amount of memory the issue more is that
over a maze of that kind of size the
amount of nodes under consideration
starts to grow really quite rapidly that
puts the memory and the computational
overhead that we don't want and also if
I'm walking down this path here let's
say and I'm here like I kind of left to
right here I call my left or right here
I can't be left and right here and I'm
spending a lot of time going to this one
adding it to the queue to this one and
then going down here I'm paying one two
three four steps when really one step
will suffice
now some spit a feed point of view at
some point I'm going to have to travel
down there but I don't really want to
store that information
we just seems a bit inefficient so what
I did was I wrote a one part which means
one look over the image algorithm to
turn this maze into a graph like the one
to La Dolce video I have no idea if it's
the optimal algorithm for this it
probably is not but it was Navin that
work and it le extends quite reasonably
to large mazes as well so let's just
have a quick look at how that works
let's go with our green pen if we do the
one path algorithm what we have to do is
make all the decisions we want to make
by just scanning across this row men
across this row and then across this row
and then across this row and you could
do it column wise but for the sake of
argument I've not done that the most
obvious thing is once we get to this
start we can flag that as a start and
that's good right so the first row we
simply move along until we get to the
start and we create a node in that
position
that's my node this will have a little
object in memory that stores it and it
will store any of its connections to any
neighbors that it can so that's our s is
the direct case RS yes but but in my
implementation this isn't just somewhere
in the array this is an actual tangible
object in memory that has a north south
east and west connection that could have
something connected to it in this case
it is not going to have a lot of
connection because you know it's not
going to go anywhere so for the next row
I came up with a number of rules that
depending on whether you're looking at
wall or looking at path you do different
things right so the first one for
example is if you're on a wall don't do
anything right you can't create a node
there you can't connect any nodes to
that point it doesn't make any sense
right so if you're on a wall but you do
nothing right and it is reflected in the
code if you're on a path and you were on
a wall then it means you were to start
something new
so we should create a node right it
starts to get a little bit confusing
what I can basically I can't with
different rules so in this one we can't
go down we can't go up we're already on
a path that we do nothing this one we've
got something above that we can connect
to so we create a node here and we join
them up and we've just created a node so
we join them up right we know which this
one is because the last one we created
on the left so we're tracking the ones
above and the ones to the left and we're
going this way down our maze so my brain
starts away can I take a break and watch
some TV and then I come back
and and I realized what okay so now I'm
at this node this goes doesn't do
anything this node doesn't do anything
because the card waffle down there's no
decision to be made at this node it
doesn't no point in making anything in
memory for here here this is an obvious
Junction we can go down from this point
so we create a node and we connect it
back to the one we last saw on the left
and then again we get to this one we're
just in front of the wall that's the end
of a Commodore I very exciting we create
a node and we join it up like this now
there's a few if statements involved in
that once you sort in your mind think
about the steps you have to take at each
given position and what was going on at
that position
it hasn't take very long to come up with
out steps you know if it's all on the
left is it all on the right is there a
path the lowest those are the things
again you have to check and they will
involve referencing the image and saying
is it a white or a black pixel for the
next one below right this one doesn't
come left or right so it's a path going
downwards we don't do anything on this
one right this one the same this one the
same on the next row this one is a
junction so we create a node and we
connect it to the last one we saw about
it which I stored in a list incidentally
for those of you following along with my
code so we get to this one this is that
this is the end of a corridor we connect
that in here we start one here because
that's the beginning of a corridor end
of a corridor connect them up this one
take no action and you get the idea
over time we start to fill in wherever
there's an interesting Junction and
anything to be done you see like this
and we propagate this through until
eventually we finish off our graph you
know what I will actually finish it off
because I went to all the trouble of
drawing out oh hang on there we are but
now if my algorithm is correct all of
these nodes should exactly reflect our
maze and what we've done is in some ways
is increased memory because these nodes
are slightly bigger objects from the
underlying array which is just small
numbers but we have to take many fewer
steps to go across this maze you know
the step count from here to here is one
instead of three and so on and depending
on the length of your corridors in your
maze you can imagine that could
drastically decrease the number of nodes
you have to be expanding into and so
then what I did was I said well okay so
I
within a maze class so I wrote a class
an object in memory that stores this
maze it has a start
it had lend and then I started writing
other classes that their only task is to
go from A to B so I did read first
search which expands all of them one
after another
emember next and then the next like a
flood fill depth-first search which
expands as far can one direction and
then the next direction and so on and
then a left turn only which is where you
always turn left and you get stuck all
the time and yet with her left fight
it's a cause of famous maze solving
algorithm because if you're human and
you can't see the whole maze it works
quite well and then I also implemented
Dijkstra and a style as well so we'll
see if it works so let's bring up the
command prompt so in an ideal world I
would have a name of the file read in
from a command line parameter right I do
actually know how to do that in Python I
was a bit lazy and I hard-coded it so at
the moment it loads tiny dot PNG because
I've told it to and that's the only made
it done so - so pi
there we are and so it creates the image
didn't take very long because this is
not a big maze in fact it took no second
to solve the maze it's only got twenty
three nodes let's see if that's true
one two three four five six seven eight
nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 18 19 20 21 22
23 oh I'm quite pleased actually because
that could have been really embarrassing
but it is that kind of debugging that I
was doing early on and getting funny
amounts of nodes and you think what I
done wrong okay I must have not
connected these properly or something
I've got a very technical question for
you what was on tell you while all this
was going on
wasn't Ellie oh yeah it's a good point
um something like that's to concentrate
on too hard if it's got a detailed plot
it's difficult for me to also do this I
can only do one thing at once it took
six ten thousandth of a second I think
that is some fraction a millisecond to
actually find the path it explored 19
nodes that means it looks at 19 possible
candidate nodes and eventually found a
path that was of length 9 through here
and if we look at the image which again
it's difficult to do on this screen so
using a magnetic of editing this will
now appear very large on your screen
rather than that which has also been
linearly interpolated which is exactly
what I didn't want to happen on this
please see my previous video on linear
interpolation so I've drawn a path
from blue to red which represents our
start to the end let's see if we can do
something a little bit more challenging
like so here I have a 2000 by 2000 image
which when you load it up on my screen
looks like a my eye pattern now I use
the program called Daedalus to generate
this and you can generate very large
mazes I'm taking it in some way on face
that there is a actual start and end
because you know it doesn't made a
slightly different to my program so I
had to go in and add to start in the end
but I can't remember what I did on this
one and so on so let's see if it works
so this was called 2000 P and G so
that's that's a hard-coded change right
run that and it will take a little bit
longer to create new maze maybe get
coffee there we go right so it took 8
seconds to create the maze and it had
seven hundred and sixteen cells and
nodes now when you consider that the
maze was two thousand pixels by 2,000
pixels which is four million pixels and
let's say half of them were white on
average then you would expect about two
thousand nodes if you were doing it the
bad way so about I've tried to save some
memory this way this potentially what
I've been doing it and then the actual
the actual worm was its depth first or
breadth-first search whichever it was I
was Brett first apparently according to
my code it takes one point one nine
seconds not very long to get through
that maze and again using wizardry I
will zoom in on this and you can see it
has found the path through so it just
looks like a general arcing path but if
we zoom in you can see it's actually
finding its way for a required
complicated maze the last thing perhaps
is that the two majors I just put in
soap imperfect mazes that means there's
only one possible solution everything
else is by definition a dead end
now some mazes aren't like that right if
you were to think of the Manhattan grid
system of the maze then in some ways
there's lots of different parts you
could take and really what you want to
do is find the shortest one the maze
I've got here has multiple solutions to
it and so for example if I run a
depth-first search on it it will be
going down the first part it finds as
far as possible and it may well not take
the shortest path because it will just
go down this path as far as I can and
that path might need to be exit it just
might be very long so if I change my
rhythm to this image and then debt first
right and we run it
okay you didn't take long 6300 nodes 100
per second to actually calculate it but
it found all kinds of stupid route
through my maze and soak all the way
down here and then up here again and
back down here now the chances I
probably cuz it just jumped across here
or something silly it just didn't occur
to it in some sense because it was
following a path that was on
I mean depth-first search and
breadth-first search for different
problems right depending on the north of
nodes you want to expand but in this
case suboptimal it would be the fact I
t's not not the optimal algorithm to use
so I've also implemented better search
and a star and Dijkstra's first dices
sorted path and so on so if I turn turn
it into Dijkstra there's a bit of
overhead because you've got to set up
your priority queue which I'm using a
Fibonacci heap to do that the code for
the Fibonacci heap also in the code feed
a spec program that yourself so if we
run this so the path lengths that debt
first fan was a fountain world and the
path length of Dijkstra found which will
be the shortest path is 197 long it's
been taking a bit longer to do it just
couldn't memory overheads mostly there
we go
so that's the actual shortest path
through that maze which is significantly
better than the last one yeah get
download the codes have a play around
see if you can work out what I've done
and what I shouldn't have done and maybe
you can fix it and then come up with
some level algorithms if you want to try
and work your way through to mate and
depend on how much RAM you have you can
see what kind of size of maze it will
handle and we look forward to seeing
some more pictures yeah it's like Python
isn't as fast as doing this in depth AC
or something like that but it's not too
bad and absolute speed is not important
for this because I was just doing it for
fun and to see you know whether it'll
work right so you know if you want to be
implemented in a fast language is lots
of point arithmetic and so on then you
know go for it but